[Music]
[Music]
oh hello hello everyone welcome back to
well I guess this is Dino DNA but really
this is me and Rob getting back together
to play some games on Thursday mornings
we did Triforce for a while we had a lot
of fun playing Legend of Zelda breadth
of the wilds not going to do something a
little bit different I am very excited
yes this is Dino DNA turns out there's a
lot of video games with Dinosaurs and a
lot of these games are weird at least in
the sense that I don't know dinosaurs
are just kind of inherently funny
they're funny and they're you know each
game will have its own representation of
dinosaurs which we will have to critique
unfortunately because dinosaurs
sometimes get a bad rap don't know that
they deserve it very much so we
originally were to start with Tarak but
I don't know I found that Tarak might be
a little bland and the this t-rex is
still going Rob just a Sturrock ie
bottom line characters my I liked her up
to better but um we wanted a a mass
amount of variety yeah as far as
dinosaurs go so we we found this one and
this is the telltale tail jesus god dang
telltale Jurassic Park the game the game
from 2011 a long time ago now 6 years
old um looking at this screen I think
it's a little bit disingenuous from the
start are not the humans the intruders
in this scenario ooh or the dinosaurs
the intruders that's a super great point
I guess we'll have to find out I said
dinos get a bad rap yeah
sky looks happy I just want friends so
if you just go to beginning episode will
start the beginning you will uh I've
never played this before nor have i but
I've had to test the audio in this
beginning is all I wanted cuz man do I
want to watch the original movie again
for the thousandth time
the music
what's your favorite dinosaur room it's
gotta be Velociraptor but your
Archaeopteryx is pretty rad
I don't know Helen it's like a it's like
a mean pterodactyl oh I think like a
one-in-three where it was where it was
just like those that whole flock of them
were stabbing that guy in the river you
mean in the movie they were like by the
way there's another Oh God
dress park three don't know this
character I'm gonna do what I'm gonna do
oh my hey day yeah wanna shave newman's
hmm shaving cream should probably put
some shaving cream on that wound or
maybe she shaved and forgot to you
shakes were made
all right if you guys got any hot Dino
facts put them in the chat a little
known fact dinosaurs have night vision
ya can see I knew that I wonder how they
found that out in an archaeological dig
its grief butchers I'm searching my
invite up it's a dinosaur
she looks worried
I don't know this is not a character I
should be familiar with right now whoa a
dinosaur or a bunny jump oh my ankle
peer pressure is on
whoops close one there you go
nice duck telltale games have come a
long way since this
and dinosaurs have psychic powers that's
not necessarily accurate again how do we
really know okay
no put your dog on a leash
uh-huh uh-huh happy Debbie Debbie Debbie
- evidently ever tap tap tap yeah keep
going probably good for you it's just a
splash Rochelle be fine
oops
[Laughter]
got this one but Oh God how is she still
alive
she seems very skinny
oh no silver hasn't - bad all right
she made it
you're just getting up yep
Hey yep what's exciting thing in video
game we've ever done so I'm still
tapping open your eyes hey we fell down
- oh good question this is unseen
playing this on pc yeah to get that full
resolution yeah oh it's a Newman yeah no
I don't want to do I do Oh fine skirt
all right difficult is it then side like
you question mark yeah here we go the
familiar music back when I was learning
a trumpet in elementary school one of
the first songs they taught me was did
it and I was like you know what I think
I'm good that's the only song I need to
know that's a great view but we are the
dinosaurs just future tops out there
sometimes they're kind of hard to spot
oh yeah
where'd you get those oh gosh jeez like
of the cows these Adam guy gave to me
your boss John hammer or whatever he
likes me oh yes generous of him yeah I
know
Thanks they're very expensive jealous
much Dino
just look around you'll find a Peter
look around uh Mohit Roy wants to know
how old is this game 2008 11 it oh you
said 11 space 2008 maybe 8 let me
double-check forget it yeah this is a
telltale game - or shaky - tree looking
at forget it just some birds okay those
are dinosaurs - yeah come on girl come
on declare yourself a scientist mine
that's a rock no see a rock
maybe there's a dinosaur hiding behind
that rock can we go down there and see
the dinos up close why would there
randomly be a dinosaur behind the random
Aurora closure that was totally
different besides there was only like
seven right and you scared the daylights
out of me
is that a dinosaur no just a building
give me those back building just a
maintenance [ __ ] wow you nailed it
dinosaurs that need repairs yeah sure we
like to keep them tuned up you know does
that shed have a bunch walls you cannot
tune up a dinosaur is worth broken they
were undergoing restoration uh-oh what
do we have here we I definitely see one
no that's just your baby brother he just
ran away actually it's a she
they're all female so which way did she
go right that's accurate all dinosaurs
are female 2011 okay my apologies thanks
we I definitely see one oh it gives me
like one second time after so this way
did she go hmm
[Music]
this game was not that well-received I'm
shocked it's kind of like mom's
bird-of-paradise only you know healthy
sounds like the Melbourne we imported
them from the mainland to brighten up
the place you guys have more flowers
here than dinosaurs now they're
good-looking flowers right so petulant
Prince go in the stream sure they do a
search yeah
she must have come out somewhere what's
your favorite dinosaur Peter your
Synology case uh yeah Archaeopteryx you
know I think your mom scribe it to us
you a bit she'd be like totally happy
come on I know she wouldn't
it's like a dragon but a real dragon and
it lays like it's dragons legs don't
they I think maybe the science is still
out on that one
hmm um there's a bunch of like dinosaur
footprints around that plants i
triceraton kind of love every dinosaur I
wasn't banana leaf even the ugly nearby
good here's a bunch of like dinosaur
footprints around that plant I
Triceratops big fans of banana leaf
they're probably nearby he said that as
if he was like holding up a script
they're big fans of banana leaf it's
never for them and safer for us
herbivores can be dangerous to stay away
from vegetarians people that's the real
lesson huh yeah I don't think fun is
quite the right word then why are we
here I want to see a dinosaur there's a
car down there must be Hammonds visitors
he's got some hotshot paleontologists
here to see the park I bet they get to
see some dinos up close we should
totally be down there there's footprints
coming out of the stream you're on the
right track
really come on okay hey there's a bunch
of them and it is even welcome Jurassic
Park
I love dinosaur I'm dinosaur violence
you remember how patchy was when your
mom got that new puppy Lady Margaret's
like that with the younger Triceratops
seriously Lady Margaret yep that's what
we call the alpha see those horns
they're more than three feet long good
fighting class right that's not gonna
happen I'm busy enough without holding
gladiator fights which reminds me
remember I said I've got a sick
Triceratops to check on oh wait I
thought he meant like a stick tricep
give me some time to pack your stuff the
boat leaves tonight remember I don't
have any stuff I practically just got
here
well at least you got a sea Triceratops
fine actually it was more like a
dominance display hmm smart ass
you're goddamn caught one on that boat
on the waves are oh yeah oh yeah
I told you Henry isn't here Matt
bastards probably stuck in a doorway
somewhere don't worry about it plan B is
ready
I have Plan B right here Henry's not
gonna double-cross us the money still
good I mean it ray I keep hearing it as
nerdy oh she doesn't know your name rich
doesn't know anything she doesn't need
to know what I check it on the line
it's Dodgson I got that's in here
Stockton's don't care isn't care God's
in my contacts gonna be here any minute
please be Newman sick pan was in general
you stole their jacket the covert op I
got a blend in yes um what about me just
follow my lead
all right what's in the photo this this
is what's gonna make us both rich oh
right that's how they smuggle out the
Dino DNA aha sure caving cream biz I'm
gonna pay him I'm gonna charge overtime
if we wait much actually relax
chances are Ned Reed's gonna show up
with that
okay yeah grow in the grass trim Rosie
Perez if anyone stops us to show them
there this is the problem we need access
passes to get past security - disgusted
- capacitor sure you wanna make a phone
call to an idiot don't let anyone see
you
I don't how about the bathroom my good
look at you boss free
okay net doll hmm got him alright new
locations available yeah this yeah
why is she speaking they've been
standing there the whole time
hey Sam just keep thinking about the
money
what was that you you say some out there
I swear I'm hearing voices
they must have extras
okay so rob him Hey look in the envelope
I kept it white I'm telling you they're
not Wow yes'm stairs there we're not
going back in that [ __ ] not today not
tomorrow
uh-huh yeah this was I think this was
one of their first what games as far as
like movie tie-ins or show right
dachshund ridiculous code name if you
spend more time on operational detail
than left I'm playing spy we wouldn't
have this problem right now if you I
don't know if you've seen it but in the
original movie you know how Newman
Newman was his name in the movie stay
warm tonight damn a number anyways the
the guy he's talking to on the dock it's
a freaking QuickTime video
it's supposed to be live right it's an
actual QuickTime video and you see like
the timeline cursor end it's like really
funny like it there's no way it could be
live it's pretty great I was watching
enemy in the state last night there's
some really good like hacker or you know
just like technology that doesn't
actually make sense that movie what am I
supposed to do be I did that
do they keep them there probably can
they probably keep them back here where
we went like five minutes ago
Oh like to magically look over here all
right yeah oh you're gonna oh nice
he's busy playing Sudoku no problem Oh
huh all right all right all right
oh you let me up here oh you got it
you're gonna call I need a phone
do the blood dudes got the phone the
guys you wish Kyle into this college
amber that's great thanks a lot very
helpful well we're hosed maybe not what
do you mean huh I got the guards phone
number call him and keep him busy
what then you sneak past and I stay here
that's not gonna work
no bubbles so I can get us the access
passes fine was that angle what I Alice
just keep him talking
no Baba sir hi hi yeah I'm clean now you
got all right we've lost some data here
and it's a bit of an emergency
give me this damn glasses like it yeah
but hold on there's one more pain it's
not just that stands dad okay yeah we're
good but hey hey hold on a second
you work for me remember that means I
know the shop you can't go that way
hello there hi
hope we have passes well that's good
this is a storm evacuation all
non-essential personnel need to leave
the island you need to get on that boat
yes I mean I have some some essential
were you rude I'm I'm with you I'm knew
about her she said she's with mailing it
she's uh gallant janitor oh good um I
can't tell you but I cannot tell you
that oh really
and why is that exactly love your
paygrade dude mm-hmm
it's very secret what's with the machete
Oh kill my partner or enough of this
[Laughter]
what's with your face hot though yes
they walking in different direction man
that was good man at least the rain is
easing up Oh engine should have paved
this whole island Wow I uh whoa are you
a dinosaur what that mr. Chadwick well
you don't like my aftershave I don't
want any accidents
yeah yeah yeah yeah come on I want to
kill him I never wanted a character in a
game to die so bad
Oh miss dating my machete got stuck in
that plan this is really good I like it
so much
hi okay yeah oh look at you like skiing
mmm
yeah my god how does this go on
we hack to the jungle silver ranked
silver Peter let's get better Louis Howe
was like I tired
[Laughter]
what is this monstrosity bag dungeon is
ruining the island it's so important to
keep people out
yeah it's more about keeping things in
no just this it's just it's sort of like
a zoo you know what I mean what is this
dialog it's so boring
I know what is always I've been to three
don't don't worry about it there's
nothing you know dangerous in there I
find a way through its checking Twitter
right now thousand four thousand
followers yeah all those teenagers on
the island what is your little - I have
to say it's a portable tracking system
sweetheart and it says that we're damn
close to that canister
what's behind the phone come on the only
thing that matters canister
you you don't seem the type for field
work yeah you track it out but in this
case I'm making an exemple
there we go
generic bar of metal was awful I bet
that means the power's out right maybe
when the hell are we gonna grant to the
darkness crazy spring do it oh if she
does a joke okay I have to tap a I've
like 30 times
ah oh thank god
I mean you know just lead the way
oh wow
like climbing wasn't any kind of like
QTE but putting your arm on a little
wire let's just skip all that looks like
grass what is it is this dog na bakke Oh
like a bird but much too big yeah I told
you it's a zoo all kinds of animals
what does she not know that their
dinosaur no no she has no idea help
she's in for the money man
I don't see species I only see dollar
seconds okay I think these might be my
my second favorite as far as dinosaurs
go just give me the Dino I can't even
move the camera right now silent okay
whatever
she just tickled that leaf yeah I really
do
- can't Sam we call him no papa
oh my god she sucks I hate this damn
junk oh look this way okay this is it we
go comes out it's nearby it's too dark I
need light and then why is your
flashlight you took it right right did I
drop it did you see me drop it
Camas over there yeah Marlana who's
gonna die first you know oh this dude
it's mister man yeah oh look at TYIN I'm
not climbing back my news to Mars I'm
gonna go around it'll be faster oh
please it's gotta be instead I am
holding the button you get a combo at
there right yeah why
oh so it in the car should be a glob
source right right it got locked in hey
where you going hey no cash only no
credit card seats taken
can't sit here
I really hope it tries to play cute
again but like next to a dead corpse
that's thick no wonder y'all think oh
yeah
one thing I know about car doors if at
first they don't open just keep pulling
on them as hard as possible yeah
[Laughter]
told you it's better to go around dummy
mm should I not even mention the
dinosaur to him yeah I'm down mmm
contact you dead
what oh you said rhe feeding on him what
the hell kind of Zoo is they listen I
told you don't worry about hey it was
just some animal Oh Mike at this at this
stage she is too deep to turn back if he
says oh there's dinosaurs I mean it
weird the canister the shaving cream
where is it
I know you took it yeah doesn't matter
you should get out of here no no no if
we leave now we don't get paid crap oh
god since gonna kill me stay here we're
gonna die gonna kill me don't worry
about him worry about that thing I'm
worried about it okay what am I supposed
to do this is some no week grading
writing dad look where it's good thing
they hired Scott Butterworth me listen
your man took a walk yeah really we
follow his dream like tracking game
that's how we find the canister I don't
want to do this okay okay that makes
sense yeah if you're just joining us
this is a whole dog bad game bad game
one of the first okay Telltale's
and all I'll check the car again just
like iMovie time I was gonna look up
other ones
so they did some CSI stuff
I wasn't no 807
the Back to the Future game before this
yeah but that was before this yeah Wow
okay I remember that game they'd better
like you know probably and then the year
after was walking dead that's soon then
after this that is
I'm tapping the button to turn my head
okay
tracks lead that way
what are her qualifications like other
than looking like a badass okay then
that's what I had that's it
I think he's dead
all right no I'm sorry okay contracts
yours better leave somewhere but we're
never getting out of here Johnny yes
this is the new tell telling what what
machete that's a qualification that's
fair
like who cares like they're trying to
relive that movie versus it's like a
weird attempt to like bring nostalgia
right like yes this is where he tied the
cable around the tree great investigated
it's a cable
help you rob want out of this so bad
this is real oh uh what I did what what
what okay their acne
why can't be in here I was so doing that
with why was you squinting is that yes
cool squint some more don't worry I want
to UM the J says dress park on s new as
backup because I want snåsa believe
don't have that on hand yeah nest thank
you might have it edification that is
exactly what I want to play too we're
gonna have that next week for sure
I know no before when I hit the the
d-pad button it would give me a
selection of places to go I don't know
what I'm doing
no no your child
oh god no here check check the Oh
animals a heavy man my heart achievers a
heavy man what's a check I started this
I want to finish it for the money
what do you mean what she loves my
can we just mr. Chadwick you can help me
with the lights on the car no listen I'm
I'm busy
God what is he doing like robbing that
guy
yeah he's leasing her be like it was you
don't even know what it was
what kind of month rows are they keeping
here I'd love to see some there he
belongs in Amman not a jungle so kill
him and move on with your life the
footprints
I find the canister okay so I gotta exit
out
what do you mean it's not letting you
know we we exit out hey Rob you gonna go
back up to that truck I got this beer we
this can't be added for my sinuses what
you do here I don't know I have fun with
this Wow oh yeah oh is that not enough
to just move on we do if we treated eff
more right more or less
just
shucks shucks this idiot aren't anything
but besides a hundred little bits of
Nedry no nothing and butterfingers
we've done all of this like a thousand
times you have to leave to point at
those magnifying lenses at one up there
you go please let that be a please like
that the end
looks like dinosaur scat Jackson do they
oh my god oh my god they robbed you how
long we've been playing this game don't
don't tell me sure you don't want to
know positive okay so that's good right
good great this is yes my sentiments
exactly
I hate that shot the most herbs walking
by like an idiot so it doesn't look
light enough to me can we can we skip
chapters I know I don't think we can
because I haven't been this kid come on
come on oh yeah uh-huh
huevos freaking bugs what who you
calling a bug the problem mm-hmm did you
find it
canisters not here
crap uh-huh so screwed we can't give up
his trail ends back coop says you gave
this 9 out of 10
something in there not a chance I never
gave thanks Ana doesn't mean much like a
dead fat dude for a week
fine I'll take a look knock yourself out
I could use some fresh air oh please so
go into the cave for some fresh air
God knew man no canister nothing
no kidding that dude just looked in this
car for like an hour ah right
oh I got more here dude no we're good oh
look at all this did he look here though
like just sweets
hey go to eat dog nice that's gorgeous
I'm speaking it the fat man no talk
about gordita oh yeah you're right you
want a canister just about this size
didn't you you didn't lose it down below
you're hitting your butthole he hit his
head and he fell they dropped the can
oh dude the guy's gone oh oh oh wow
jitterbug gee the 500-hour kind of fine
in the state of California
got it got it
Wow
maybe I knew I'd find you oh great
yeah it's a can of soup and I'm Abe
Lincoln attend use usage millions
invested it's the next one with more
screw engine this is it the crown jewels
they lose control of this they got
nothing I need to see him dinosaur yeah
yo honey don't tell me you thought we
were after shaving cream dinosaurs don't
understand you don't need to understand
it wouldn't take one of these that's
just super great boy good
please gamers says how does she not see
the Jurassic Park low going on his
jacket and not have any reaction oh
don't don't move
no reason oh hell yeah yeah rule in fact
Diplodocus understand Spanish nice shot
nice one Turner good shooting yeah oh
he's blind that's why gone great now we
don't see another diet dinosaur for what
another half-hour yeah do you see that
that's how you do it yeah that's what
you get you little punk Mortimer come
out outta here okay all right
all right you know the plan my boys are
sending a boat we bring him the cannon
weird how to make something over his
face oh it's been it's been on Oh
to the meeting place not that's
monstrous around here we'll take the car
also on the car all day here and dude
that spit is like paralyzing yeah right
now schemes not supposed to burn him
right oh yeah like it's helis memory
it's like sticky [ __ ] what let's
dispense chiming for what
yeah push it on the plastic why are we
getting suspenseful swells what is wrong
oh my god
dangle cover this is how he dies
all right
what hey we got gold that time oh no
don't worry Rob he's fine
where's the head you should have bought
attention see that no I can't
all right okay okay I don't think she's
I don't think she's figured out other
dinosaurs a woman even though he said it
thank you ever not shut up good on the
movement in the nuts they had lights on
the boat thinking never go into the
field
chitosan lowly god I think you should
hit the ref to the right trigger here
not me please oh I had to oh I'm sorry I
don't know I might tell him to shut up
thank you clapping yeah what
we're safe favor and just keep your
mouth shut okay remember when this
there's this whole like narrative of her
not knowing what is on the island I
think he was a zoo now she could you
didn't get pissed about it at all
no she I don't there was no I'm gonna
put it away for dog that's good we're
gonna sit and wait that's funny
give you my gun why is that funny models
we just need to stay alive until dawn
that's your plan we'll never make it
battles as I think they're gonna have
stop the car did you take our clothes
off and huddle for warmth hey let's get
these pants on it's got nothing to do
with the game but I've got a moustache
hair climbing up my nose right now oh
yeah I'm sorry
no worries whoo as you saw it's the car
in the dark that's right no fix it and a
dark battery I can't think of a family
character right now that horse mascot
yeah recharge that battery with your
hand rub you check the valve the guy who
does my party you always check to the
bow shut up for once
am i well I think you don't hold it up
you please pick up the pain dude I don't
let me say it's just one prompt your
back and forth shut up miles hurry
I think this game so much if anyone in
the chat knows what the hell we're
supposed to do you check the bow the guy
who does my for cheat he always checks
the bow shut up
yeah for real what the [ __ ] screw you
telltale this is [ __ ]
geet I don't know what to do check the
guy who just like porky he always checks
the bow shut up
dude I that I I've been doing that what
oh you can pause what hold on covers you
middle stay in the middle enjoy oh stop
when the lights turn on when oh thanks
guys
he's just got you Dan alright thank you
guys here we go
Wow good thank you Jason thank you
everyone
huh or not cuz now we gotta keep playing
this thing it's true Oh No thank you
there we go
a part of me just wants to do not do any
of this just so we can see some like
like a - no problem
I am I'm in that like you know what I
mean I just want to I just want to see I
really do know what you mean just wanted
well justice back on is gay dancers
their dad maybe see your pass yeah
license is a ma'am I will throw up on
you
Burnie James yeah you got a dollar here
we're out of here
cool dude you can play this game for
almost an hour that died I was asked
hoping you wouldn't do that I did it you
did yeah we meant to have a Jeff
Goldblum sound board ready but um I feel
like no one's like updating sound boards
these days to be anything other than
like the first version of flash yeah hey
are you going in town
[Laughter]
what bothers me the most about this is
that we already know how this is going
to end
[ __ ] all right that was rude he
knows not what he's doing
Oh what that knocked you out and a cliff
later no she's fine yes clearly a
linebacker you want to let it happen
yes more than that that's a good ramp
yeah well they say dinosaurs aren't very
intelligent the baby's good yeah I don't
want to press it as much nice sir what
there's a bigger dinosaur it's showing
up yeah
take his wallet touches but yeah just do
something look more surprised
now shave don't smirk at the canister
now if those dinosaurs come back I'm
gonna be Oh Peter it's a real shitty
abrasion what's up I think we got
ourselves oh no oh it's those other
dinosaurs we saw in the beginning
assuming I was about to say philosopher
after God I want to see one of those we
had a hot time we are officially late I
was ready when you said shut up dad
it's fine sweetie player hon about us
you're coming to Dallas oh just to the
mainland I have to be back after the
storm just a Dallas's in your land
what do you it's weird that fence lights
are out have mouths animation it's like
I'm sure but it just needs to replace
him
it's going good Bob Jones so everything
you guys for sticking with us yeah
boring
you said it he said it can't help you
have but your muscle test run in my book
as far as an episode goes first episode
yeah yeah we're uh we're gonna have Jess
more the next week sure yeah we're gonna
pick a game that is a chock-full of
dinosaurs rather than one that's just
just teasing honestly about the
shoplifting I was just like part of the
reason why I mean I I was in for this
game was because one I was uh I was
she's led to believe because the trailer
was pretty dumb better be you know maybe
a little more of a quicker pace as far
as action those but my god I didn't know
that just honestly if I knew about that
miles guy I wear office me oh yeah oh
this is it tap it I'll tapped her I
guess
oh my god is she dead no no this is a
video game honey she's fine breathing
she's totally fine who are you yeah can
you tell me your name this is strange
it's like some kind of human she needs
medical attention
we've got to get her to the visitors
center we just cut to that can we not go
through all the red whirls or do that
doesn't matter were you serious when you
said you can drive a stick yeah we want
mom doesn't know I don't know of any
other tell yourself tell game better
dress apart so I think this is a oh yeah
um all right let's go we gotta get her
out of here
i'ma do overtime you are really letting
your daughter down oh my god that's what
it was easier than grabbing the wire
fence but here's the thing right spritz
me oh my god he's ready implies for the
Dinos uh what she drive what we did yeah
there was talking about that this is
this is something else
sorry I wasn't paying attention driving
a stick was not a youth motorcyle
alright oh damn uh here's the thing is
earlier he was pretty calm right yeah
during the movie as far as like the time
frame dude the park is like bruising is
showing of it it's like - all of the
powers out and was a lot force Oracle
all the all the cages have been broken
everyone suppose be evacuated as like
God relay maybe if I kiss her neck it's
only 33
she's speaking in tongues mister slow
down for losing irked okay you better
slow down a bit hon sorry there give her
a hickey maybe if I give her an ugly
that's just like a reaction to a
parasitic infection
maybe maybe toxoplasmosis
if you don't know six pinner centers
come on
see it with me now just keep driving
sorry I just farted damn bean burritos
I'm pressing the right snake just let me
do something oh it's a Resident Evil
game thank God okay sorry I know my fart
[Laughter]
damn park burritos wait this is am I
going to tell her I'm a woman
yeah listen to me you need to let me
help you no no listen I'm a doctor I'm
gonna make it better
Rico yes medic oh I'm going to disinfect
your wound now okay yes I speak Spanish
here we go where is that well that
should keep the infection at bay that's
it you were doing out there hey man we
can make time sir Sir Tim right we make
a good med fresh idiot heroin yeah honey
honey
dad gotcha you ink nice crab dude dude
that needles gonna be so infected from
rolling around that disgusting Jeep
don't worry I am holding the X button oh
I see keep your eyes driving skill yeah
Wow boo why is he smiling so much keep
her stable
I'm gonna get her bandaged up you okay
to keep driving
yeah I'm good how long ready for my
learner's permit okay I don't think mom
needs to know about it I don't think mom
needs to know that we're we're dinosaurs
of killing people but this toxic
alteration just doesn't make sense yeah
what is that Laurie Adi is real creepy
it's Jess why are we stopping I nailed
it
no she's beautiful she right right well
we're lucky this young ones by herself
wouldn't want to meet the Alpha out here
Lady Margaret she's pretty protective
meanwhile açaí family creeps emerge even
without the usual genetic relationship
looking great Guster to join the family
the moment they did go right sorry this
little ones name is Paquita what is she
doing way out here you have a dying
woman in your heart history lesson I've
got to get this critter back in roll oh
sure is there a scene in this game where
you get to examine a huge mound of turd
I'll just be a sec wait you can't wait
to see that cutie oh yeah
easy good I come in peace Lucic Alamosa
feel like I feel like I'm writing this
on the fly and that's how they rode this
easy girl
Pat its but get right through that but
[Laughter]
did you try again on that button did you
get out here did you push this gate open
huh do you understand English
Mary cold no my name is Harry nope but I
could use a better idea
mmm I'm work she's got multiple ideas
give up quick
Kame so good locked in the open position
should be a manual release in the shet
but didn't I say to wait in the car it's
no big deal
see we're all right medico por que oh
she's okay she's alright she's just
getting to know you
right Paquita right Terry [ __ ] not it
I need to get this girl out of the way
now that you've met her up close would
you please go back to the car stop
calling it a girl it's a new faces make
her nervous she'll be a lot easier to
manage if you're in the car it's a it's
a big-ass dinosaur that's causing you
problems now and there's some dangerous
[ __ ] happening enough to get you out of
the way right I need to unlock the gate
from the main he should stay away from
it and drag it off the trail how about
that or stab it with a needle I don't
care [ __ ]
madacorp walking hmm how's she doing
back there honey
I think she's dead Oh Tom that problem
he just crapped herself now about this
lever fence repairs work boots snow
shovels those before
well it's not for shoveling snow yes we
are oh really
you see let me just push this handle ah
code is 69 red means nine
red beans locked should be a manual for
this Xavier now that move her food oh oh
my god Jessie look at the glove box for
me there should be a manual in there
with access codes to the shed the glove
box why do we need gloves dad mm-hmm
excuse us find those cards give me a
second yeah look for the access codes
for the Triceratops maintenance shed
okay oh here we go one five six three
three seven three three exactly where
that feeling sweetheart wait do I have
to remember what that code was oh my
okay cool
that would be amazing Cyrus Drake is
right
he's like I'm already lost why are they
trying to get in this building Oh cuz
this is why
that ought to do it now to get Becky
though away from her snack yes
here look
come on girl let go come on this is the
road not a restaurant oh my mistake uh
but that tongue is just licking that
thing I did Jabba the Hutt soul I give
up
magical I give up
there's plenty to eat in your paddock
girl come on let's go wrong what what's
this prompt here with the trigger maybe
you have to like asset questions hey
honey how's our patient doing I don't
know okay I guess how's her breathing
okay I guess she's kind of snoring
yes Cyrus is right feel like a woman
something dying uterine rammed freaking
Triceratops no no how do I know what
imagine okay say I'm eating here oh good
you honk it and it'll know vo there yep
okay so when that happens then you have
the other dude grab it oh yeah
left-right d-pad i pressed up on the
d-pad really Oh perfect he's distracted
by the horn uh-huh so you're switching
back and forth right yeah but you know
how convoluted it is why are you walking
away why would he go there why does he
have to go there for it to then switch
to the car what the
oh my god yeah tell her tell her to do
something
Jess just try the lights or the horn or
something anything to get her attention
okay okay okay
[Applause]
but I know I why is it dad why doesn't
it tell me I would tell me little lights
two on the right are RV nice fun fact
Triceratops hate light
[Music]
dude's got the breakaway cargo pants on
my dreams ya know I can close that gate
so do it just do it just don't make me
do it
[Music]
[ __ ] yeah they look at you oh it's gonna
get out oh girl come on girl
what are you doing girl drat Jess give
me the shotgun why dad
where's the mommy bit
shut up whoa it's your mama
oh yeah baby Peter get get that
controller ready there's no way I could
have done that
Yeah right that's fine that's fine
turning off the car long oh wow
cool yeah put your hands back on the
wheel
I'm gonna eat you like my hat
you didn't say anything about my hat I
just guess Jess Hotwire the car
[Laughter]
okay medic oh she's still in the
backseat yeah doll should I put it
yep no not really
it is painful to play Brandon how's it
going here I heard the horn Oh Jess Jess
that is the t-rex the Alpha Jess isn't
it just gorgeous look how it walks ah
just what the [ __ ] am i doing Jess don't
tell your mom's not there do you see
what I'm doing
let it happen baby let it happen alright
it's not your dad anymore
Oh death hey death toll - dude nice you
ok no that's good it's a good thing oh
all this again that's cool
where's the where's the famous ripple
man
I couldn't get the rights to it hey
what's up Jess free look guys I don't
want to be that guy but it's 11 p.m.
we're trying to sleep
all right here uh-huh uh-huh oh it's
like climbing up climbing a ladder it's
just like real life
yeah it's just like real life Wow how
are you gonna get out of this pickle by
the skin of my khakis no doubt yeah out
of horn brake the horn off make the horn
on skis flossing
it's doing the worm blocks
whoa Peter duck swish you know what he
looks like and I'm now realizing he
looks like one of the characters from
Team America just that like oh that like
doll face
nod or like a pretty alpha version of
Nathan Drake right oh please please hey
dance oh yeah uh Peter I think I think
you should let her die I don't think
they're gonna let me they're not gonna
let a little girl by oh oh yeah he just
shook his head like he was disappointed
in her just I'm not angry I'm just
disappointed
don't tell Mom okay they're not gonna
let her die beste death goes to the
little girl in the game
hey I'm still here what uh just one more
time please oh look all these different
types of debts we can do Peter it's a
home run
out of the park Oh
all right that's enough death for now
you were hard you were honking that horn
weren't you I get early in the morning
[Music]
are you gonna make my kids lunches
you're gonna drop them off at school
know how it those guys are so distracted
come on come on come on
[Music]
I don't think this is this would be an
accurate fight hey we'll help chat me
out then help did that help you can chat
me up
Oh oh yeah yeah whoa reaction is a lot
longer than her dad oh no bleep oh dude
uh
part of me really wants to see that guy
get checked again that was that was my
favorite and I can't bring myself to do
this oh it's really good Joel on the
chest
he literally sent her distract so you
could escape Cyrus's please again I
can't I don't know be [ __ ] either it's
too long unless see any of this again
okay this is also what's really bugging
me is that Myles got the lamest death
yeah our main characters they put all
this effort into this girl getting
rocked
how what no no no that was an accident
up that's fine do it again do it I'm
[ __ ] well I'm not gonna do any better
[ __ ] no I thought they was oh hey how
you doing I'm a little lost
oh it is a dinosaur
man t-rexes are [ __ ] cool
Oh move your half
look dad look at me
I put what is 8 f8 f 8 MA
I mean we could see another
start some mega now there uh dad what
the yeah she's good
once again JJ scolex laptop laughing
that was funny I mean come on
yeah let them give them a little
downtime all my stress well that should
get her through the night
what touching her neck we'll get her
proper treatment collarbones huh
everything's just back to normal we're
safe now this is our look let's play
shadow puppets I only know why remember
that even go to sleep without it
yeah dinosaurs can't get through that
door right I don't think they have
access cards no cuz Raptors can't open
doors not a chance
that's solid steel yeah yes sweetheart
what solid steel fight each other yeah I
was so awesome it's so sleep honey did
you go this is messed up
Harding oh that oh this is like job dude
how can you sleep this is a messed up
relationship alright time to kill Mitch
and put out this woman yes drink allows
your daughter
just load this book he uses it on self
sleep roll credits
mmm I'm having a lab that no one bullet
ought to do everyone keeps talking about
gravy yeah Chet would you like a napkin
for that gravy on your lips
what I don't know I want to know more
because I was drilling is this a ps2
game might as well be but no it's a PC
game I think it maybe came out on xbox
360 yeah I did shoot her indeed shoot
her in the foot I guess I'd better oh I
should just open it it just became
morning very quickly
oh he woke up oh sorry I stopped paying
attention for a second it's all good
also what was that and I just did check
my gun yep still here well better open
it
oh it's unlocked
I love this guy's Lauren and George how
are you well what did he just do
he just pop a shell out yeah
when did he prefer whatever thank we
Peter but the cry out his game is like
making my stomach hurt which I don't
know how that works but well I don't see
any dead Triceratops
why is he squinting like that even so I
have a feeling old ones as well a this
isn't yeah I got a feeling midge got
away she triangle okay but that's beyond
unacceptable I gotta talk to Muldoon so
Jane are you go down you know it
whatever let this happen has to be held
again this this doesn't work in the
timeline at all he has no idea what's
going on hitchhike we get on the road
and get moving someone is bound to come
along horrible idea you know a t-rex
don't be stupid honey should we touch
that fence hmm honey go test what nice
wouldn't that be awful if he taught her
about dinosaurs who shadow but it's
significant all that for like ten
minutes
that's friggin awesome spit and baling
wire like everything else in this damn
Park I like your jaw nice not the only
one to use work is he a quick time thing
again what time thing again that wild
live video huh we're miles away and the
access road is we're miles away damn
those two were standing
how are you hi oh look at its is this a
minigame if I did not mean it to
telephone but in Hanks this is so cool
this is gonna be just as slow as the
movie what should I do
security yeah right control
bbbbb it'll be damned
they must have psychic Oh Darrin
[Laughter]
security access maybe do I have to turn
oh my god this is the dumbest person
agree you want a magic you're I've got
some justice for you
poopy what hit X Rob obviously had a and
B and Y and X and all just seems back
hacking am i right oh shoot studly
of course all right we've got access
let's see what we can do with it control
well isn't that helpful
data sure what is the this note on the
bottom right Paris our altruism meerkat
oh my god
[Laughter]
meerkats Oh someone is helping us out
thank God treats Thank You Cyrus that
bedsheet is horrendous Oh for crying out
loud
zip Trek check oh he was just messing
with us I was hoping that actually be
something helpful yeah cuz what's kind
of neat I like that
nope let's get rid of all those working
files real quick
good good making progress where was I
just now I don't know do we go to Nedry
land already yes okay did we go well
there's more in there I think we did all
this okay that's where we just were ok
so then a great grand
wonderful mm-hmm god those are options
telephone a' trunk great Oh looks like
the trunk line at the Visitor Center is
back up does that help us no tour
vehicles someone say we do all the
security I'm pretty sure we did yeah
this is dwarf Eagles okay okay okay
thanks guys
oh great look at all these just hook the
system's online or I like it
well I guess we go vehicle one first
how long have I been saying this whole
park is doomed to catastrophic failure
how long have we been stuck with your
adaptability just do whatever done what
are we even trying to do do you know we
got now six more minutes fingers
oh cool that was it
hey do you want to play no feel like
life just doesn't have any meaning why
why are we here at Missouri was it to
play this somebody knows we're here
told me never ever hit me except when
you're on an island full of dinosaurs
come on honey let's get our patient
Mexico okay
his tour cars only go a few places cool
yeah sh-she can totally sit like that
she's passed out you can hear us we need
to go to the visitors center ADA says
you're pissed I'm surprised it's only
one let's get them to the center are you
Peter I'm livid dude you can tired us I
think there's a great game from the
ground this time I think it's gonna take
forever
rabbit last year oh hello whoa see see
the future you're safe now you're gonna
be fine
what is with her eyes what do you that
was big cat what's happening she's
delirious she could be hallucinating
let it
[Music]
angel that's actually what I would ask
first
Sammy's gotta rest my Spanish isn't that
good I can do though [ __ ] just tell her
she needs to rest
gracias yeah your mouth was closed oh
hell yeah
yogurt yo necesito necesito wow I didn't
say that quite right [ __ ] dude
is this the last thing we do yes Veta
how are we supposed to do
this is horrible
Ghora requir the fellow oops oh dude
this is
deal
a Vita no sorry
[Music]
la resto I can't believe it you do this
this is this is horrible it doesn't mean
what I thought it no but everything else
means exactly what you thought god
if someone in the chat has any idea
she's infected shoot her she's this is
the tie-in to Walking Dead
calm
Budhia
[Music]
not peace manly lobby know who they are
okay okay okay I see you guys thank sir
she needs rest
yeah I got it oh my god okay it's a dead
dad necesita
Descanso see see it's like ah ah ah all
that she's Benjy gonna like she's been
arresting for the last hour kind of
forged that sorry maybe call it buddy
but I like a day look I think this is
our stop this is this is a really good
game how many dinosaurs out of ten one
out of ten this is really bad okay I
will give man the only cool part was
when we saw him all good wrecked by that
t-rex oh there they go
peace island is yours hey can somebody
help us please eyes for caught yeah
let's do it
sorry guys and stomach but thank you
thank you very much for watching uh this
is the first of many episodes of Dino
DNA uh not sure what we're gonna play
next week
uh oh where do we go I gotta go back
here i the the kid and one of these
settings got messed up sorry okay yes uh
yeah sorry to cut off um absolutely we
will have the better game next week
maybe a better Jurassic Park game a
better drastic park game I'm thinking
it's Ness if we can cut if we can find
it okay um and we have got to get a Jeff
Goldblum soundboard in here that'll
happen that will hat that will hat
promises have been made and started if
anyone knows Jeff Goldblum could you
have him reach out to us I just like to
get him on the show that'd be really
great it's unrealistic but I'd yeah but
yeah so you know leave his cell phone
number in the comments and we'll get
right to it alright alright thank you
guys so much and have a great rest of
the week take care bye bye
you